this morning the story of a family
paying tribute to a lost brother by
reviving a lost part of new york city
feldman's hot dogs were the first and
original hot dogs before nathan's or
anyone else invented by a german
immigrant in the 1800s the feldman story
is not well known around most of the
country but it's legendary in coney
island the famed brooklyn beach
destination
a trio of brothers grew up hearing
stories of the old feltman's restaurant
and now two of those brothers have
brought feltman's back
carried by the memory of the one they
lost
i always had a thing for history i was a
former a teacher
and i love new york city history you
know i just my family's been here our
family has been in new york city for
over 200 years 202 years
mike jimmy and joe quinn were always
taught to have big dreams
part of a proud irish family in a city
known for big ideas
one entrepreneur the boys always heard
about was charles feltman who in 1867
invented the hot dog
at its peak in the early 1900s
some believe feldman's was the largest
restaurant in the world feltman would
serve
ten thousand people
in one sitting so to put that in
perspective
battery park city
has ten thousand residents so picture
feeding battery park city
every evening that's feltments the quinn
brothers were raised on success stories
like feldman's
20 years ago it seemed like they could
be on their way too with joe enrolling
at west point and jimmy getting a high
profile job in manhattan's financial
district
then came 911.
jimmy was on the 104th floor of the
north tower just a few floors above
where the first plane struck does it
feel like 20 years
it it does it
for us it's every day after the attack
joe says he went looking for revenge
spending a dozen years in the army
serving three tours in iraq and
afghanistan
mike looked for meaning what happened i
was left alone
that decade after 9 11 was hell with a
capital h it was very lonely very sad
and i think me just falling in love with
the city going to places that have been
here
for over a century really made me fall
in love with the city again
mike started doing history tours at
coney island
then six years ago over beers at
mcsorley's ale house the oldest irish
saloon in new york city and a personal
favorite of jimmy quinn's
mike and joe made a pact to revive a
dream they once had with their now
fallen brother
it was time to bring feltman's back
that's a delicious hot dog it's
tremendous
it's got that snap
juices flow out it really does not like
your normal hot dog
today the reborn feldman's is the
fastest growing hot dog company in the
country
one of the places you can get them is of
course right here at mcsorley's
for the bar where the beer options are
simply lights or dark this marked the
first change to their menu in over 60
years
this meant more to me bringing feltments
to mcsorley's then back to coney island
or anywhere else
mike is the face of the feltman's
operation
joe is logistics
jimmy the soul i guess there's a lot of
people who order a feltman's hot dog
here
and maybe don't understand
everything that's behind it yeah and
that's the importance of of you and and
things like this to just tell the story
that this isn't just
um a bar that this isn't just the hot
dog this is part of new york history
it's part of family history it's just
you know how can we
make a little money in business but also
make a big impact and tell those stories
and have our loved ones live on
getting excited already
what do you think jimmy would think
about feltman's he would think it was
insane you know just if you could play
academy he would just be like i can't
believe you guys pulled it off and i
can't believe you're trying to pull it
off without me but you're not pulling it
off without him he's he's still in you
guys i mean and he is exactly and we
really do think is a small business
going against bigger businesses with
more resources jimmy's our competitive
advantage today three-quarters of
feldman's employees are veterans mike
and joe also formed a non-profit called
three brothers that sends money to gold
star families we have a mission beyond
selling hot dogs do you want people to
think about that when they buy feltmans
of course and we'll do whatever we can
to to support those people that gave the
ultimate sacrifice those goals to our
families and those veterans that are
that are suffering really hard right now
suffering hard especially now joe says
because of the recent resurgence of the
taliban in afghanistan following the u.s
withdrawal
he spent the past few weeks acting as
counselor and friend it is a stain on
our country that we're leaving afghan
interpreters and those that
um helped us there
behind and in those images of the of
afghans that worked with us you know
jumping onto to aircrafts and trying to
get on that needs to be fixed there
needs to be solutions not blame of this
president or that president this person
to this what's the solution to help
those people now and into the future
and then the second half of that how are
we going to help our veterans that are
dealing with severe moral injury um of
putting their lives and and having
friends that were
having killed in afghanistan and
and for families to see
you know what what transpired and that's
what we've done over the last 20 years
it's just a shame and guess what we're
all going to forget about it after this
weekend but who's not going to forget
our military veterans and gold star
families and and and those who gave the
ultimate sacrifice and our veterans that
served there and even in iraq
and what are the mental health resources
that we need to provide for them
it's just it's still worth the emotion
on this day the 20th anniversary of 9 11
joe and mike will once again be back at
the september 11 memorial where they'll
pay tribute at the site where jimmy died
my mother and i have never missed a year
we do it for jimmy you know more than
anything because we know that he'd want
someone here to represent him when the
name his name is paul
then they'll get back to work at a place
where he lives on you know to me
although war is complex all of 911 is
complex i think of it like mcsorley's
right you have two choices
light ale or dark l and sometimes in
life you have two choices the light or
the dark and i'm just glad that six
years ago mike and i chose the light
so are we
beautiful
it really was um no um no formal recipe
was ever passed along so but they used
to talk about how their grandfather
would always tell them about what made
the perfect hot dog all the way down to
the casing right wow what i love about
stories like this is how we peel away
an understanding of what's behind
something we knew nothing about
and you think about it next time you
have one yes you will yeah